when you shared that you were bullied as
a kid but it helped you learn a valuable
lesson and what was that
um to stop focusing on what other people
think so much amen you know i feel like
the
moment i realized that i was
searching for approval is when i
realized that i was so unhappy with that
like
it was my opinion that i needed of
myself to keep me happy
like i think i'm beautiful i think i'm
funny i think
i don't have to look to other people to
know those things about myself
yeah you know the funniest thing ever
did you ever see the labyrinth you're
too young
did you see the labyrinth oh david oh
okay i was gonna say i'm like a decade
older than usual
um but um i i'd love that movie and i
was bullied too as a kid i was just an
awkward
i'm still awkward but i love it i leaned
in but i i don't know i think at the end
part you know when she says you have no
power over me
and it was really a lesson it sounds so
funny because it was such a film to get
a lesson from but i
it really is about i tell my daughter
that all the time because i'm like you
give your power to your
little brother every time you let him
have that attention he wants negative or
positive attention you're giving him
that power
like quit letting him get to you and
it's the same thing i think it's
applicable in our society like in in the
industry and online like people
always have something to say about you
and it's like don't give them your power
don't feed it like you know fuel it but
i think don't feed the fire i think it's
important though that we talk about it
because i think a lot of kids go through
that stuff
um you know regardless of what you look
like where you come from i think that
however
everywhere want more fun stuff i thought
so
check out these videos floating around
my head this one is really cool
i'm just saying no pressure